hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm amanda and this is the samuel and
amanda show where we talk about money
marriage and life money money from
yorkshire money
money marriage and life i'm sure you
like a bit of money we like a bit of
marriage and life is for everybody so
this week we are going to be talking
about what we're going to be talking
about having a job pros and cons it's
good and
whether you should be in business
whether you should stay employed what's
what's best so employment versus
unemployment no not unemployment
hopefully that's an option employment
versus self-employment or having a
business having a job are jobs
underrated or overrated what do you
think
ah
overrated probably because everyone does
it i think definitely overrated however
does that mean
that a job is always a bad thing you've
probably heard me say that j.o.b stands
for jump out of bed on a journey of
boredom to be just over
bro
[Laughter]
right so jobs can suck and what part of
what we do with our academy and our
training programs is we help people get
out of their job however we're going to
be discussing whether um there is a plus
side to job so why don't you start by
talking a little bit about um your
your your kind of upbringing because
when you grew up it was all about
education it's about getting a job and
then when we got married it was like
whoa so we had a lot to talk about maybe
you could share your story but before
amanda goes on to share her story about
jobs and her experience what do we need
the guys to do we need you to like this
video and also subscribe to see more
content absolutely share the video like
it drop a comment if you've got
particular topics or themes or ideas
that you want to see us talk about
comment below so mandy go ahead what's
your perspective of a job and what
happened okay so um my side of the
family i was i was brought up to go to
university get a job and everyone's
employed and so the business side was
never really a thing that i ever really
considered for myself i just thought i'd
find a career that i loved and then just
be in it and then when we got together
as you said it was kind of like whoa
of what you know what what should we do
and the first because it was so funny
because the first one mandy first
started finding out about my when i told
her about my business and stuff
he was like oh it's amazing obviously
but because i owned a lot of houses
right when we got married i had a lot of
houses was making very decent income um
but then when we got married amanda's
idea was still kind of like oh but i
should still keep a job though just to
keep a bit of security i'm like yeah it
was it was a safe place because what he
was doing was risky it's like yeah but
what i was doing was earning like
far far no i know i know but without the
security of the job but obviously as we
know jobs are not you know secure
exactly
any time
um so
i was in a place where it was like
samuel was like quit your job quit your
job quickly
and i was like
but i also loved what i did as well so
um i mean eventually i did quit my job
and for me i think it was like the best
decision because i've never looked back
i was working and at uni and then i
graduated when we were just after we got
married so i've been working for five
years um but i think what i found was
when i left my job when i quit and then
i was working on a business that i you
know loved i was more engrossed i
probably worked harder than i did when i
was employed and i don't know i just
think that you have a bit more
motivation if you're loving what you're
doing as a business you've got gotta
love what you do i think that's the
biggest thing in terms of a job is a job
good or is it bad and the answer is it
depends
what we teach people to do
is quit their jobs when they don't like
their jobs so we have people um you know
that might be working in retail not the
retail's bad but they don't like it
they're just spending the whole day
clock watching
if you're spending your day clock
watching you can't clock watch your life
away that is a misery so you know we've
had people in retail making 1500 pound a
month from their salary and then they
very quickly learned about how to
package and sell deals and they just
quit immediately um what about ellen and
ashley
ellen and ashley they were teachers and
they quite enjoyed their job yeah they
were teachers and they were working in i
think they're working was it dubai i
think it was dubai i think it was
somewhere in the middle east yeah and
they um really wanted to do property
they weren't getting fulfilled in their
job as teachers because of a bits of
bombs with red tape you have to speak to
them and they
flew from dubai
to england to meet me and they came on
one of my training programs
and they just said you know what if we
go back to dubai and we go back to our
teacher jobs
it's so full on it it requires us to be
in a country that we don't particularly
want to live in all of our time all our
attention we're going to do this until
we die
we're going to do this like forever and
we haven't got time to do a job and do
property so they made the executive
decision while they were in england just
after the training they quit their job
on the spot right now they didn't go
back
they just quit the job on the spot and
and i wasn't happy about that i was like
whoa
but it's a personal decision what about
melissa we've been chatting with us just
this morning yeah which prompted this
this
question right now what happened yeah so
my sister um she's a qs and she's gonna
be getting married um to someone who's
full-time in property and she's also had
property experience because she's been
on the train and on your training and
she's had experience deal sourcing so
she knows how much money she can make
she's done that but she's still decided
that even after she's got married and
stuff she still wants to stay in her job
and what did i say to her and you were
like that's great that's really right i
said that's the best decision yeah yeah
right she's married to well she's not
married yet she's getting married to
james armstrong who probably you know
you've seen him on winners on wednesday
she herself has been on winners on a
wednesday because she came on some of
the training she did four deals
they've bought a castle together so
these guys are successful yeah
amanda's sister our sister
does not need to have a job no right she
doesn't need to have a job but why is
she staying at the job
she's staying because she loves it and
she feels that it's good challenging for
her she loves being in that environment
and she's doing really well in that
environment as well she is she's 23 yeah
she's flourishing in her career i won't
say what she's paid because she probably
wouldn't want me to say
but what i will say is for 23
like yes very very very good crazy yeah
you can make good money on a job and if
you enjoy a job and you're making good
money on a job what's the problem do you
know that 80 percent of millionaires are
employees
did you know that no i didn't know that
true facts 80 of millionaires are
employees wow because sometimes people
think an employee is someone that's not
valued that's scoffed at that's treated
like a [ __ ] that often might be the
case but an employee sometimes also like
we've got employees do we treat our
employees like [ __ ] yeah absolutely
no we treat them like business partners
you know we ask them their that we ask
them their opinions on stuff we promote
them we give them opportunities they
feel like they're working on the
business as opposed to working as as a
[ __ ] i hope i thought but if they
didn't feel like that if they didn't
enjoy the job i'd be the first to help
them and support them and champion them
on to leave
because
ultimately it's about life is about
choices enjoying life being fulfilled
and if you can't do that in a job then
get a business but if you can do that in
your job keep your job but
make sure that you're paid well make
sure that you save part of your money
and you invest everybody even my staff
everybody should be in investing in
property not everybody should be deal
sourcing not everyone should be doing
rent to rent if you're in a job that's
giving you good fast plan and you love
it
focus on that what do you think yeah no
i totally agree and also if you're in a
job
give value be a valuable member of staff
like don't just be in a job and be like
because i know lots of people that are
at work but they're not really in it and
it's like if if you want to get paid
more then you should be doing more and
you should become a person of value yeah
we we was a really good point we
actually banned our staff a couple years
ago from because we used to
pay extra if someone worked overtime so
if they were working if they went on to
work throughout the evening they'd tell
us and we'd pay them extra for it but
then we'd stop that because we realized
that people were thinking in terms of
they're trading their time for money but
even an employee is not trading their
time for money no one is trading their
time for money what you're doing is
you're exchanging
value for money you get paid for your
value
not for your time yeah that's really
really key point and you need to
remember that if you're in a job right
yeah definitely and you got to the point
what you quit in the end yeah what did
you did
you don't know how great jobs are yeah
the true reason why i quit was the
holiday days
i didn't like you really wanted to
travel and stuff and i used the former
holiday days and then it got to the
point where it was like i actually can't
go on holiday and whereas i found that
obviously being having my own business
enabled me to be free you get more
freedom but you do work harder so you
know that's why we're going back now
like six and a half years yeah six and a
half years can you believe it we've been
married a long time sweet pie no um so
also a guy called i mean there's so many
there's some people that i've literally
i'll meet with them and i'll be like
quit your job tomorrow because they
don't like it and they're not paid well
and they've got no one depending on them
anyway just quit there's other people
like asita for instance one of our
academy members
lovely guy he's making i'm not going to
go into the ins and outs because it
wouldn't be fair on him but all i'll say
is he's making more he's on a good in a
good job very good job making good
salary but he's making more
on his rent to rents
than he is on his job
so most people think well quit
quit what are you doing he enjoys his
job
his family are depending on him he's got
a big beautiful family he's also um
where about is he from nigeria i think
he's from nigeria he's got people in his
back in his family that are depending on
him as well and i said to him look your
rents might be making you more but rent
to rent are a little up and down
so i don't feel comfortable with you
quitting your job just yet i told him
that and he's not quit his job just yet
um and he enjoys his job yeah so i think
it's a real independent personal
decision um also risk depends on your
appetite for risk if you've got zero
appetite for risk have a job yeah
right even though technically a job is
more risky than
your your life in someone else's hands
put your life in someone else's hands
have a job um
i personally don't care about taking
risks i would be happy to have nothing i
don't i don't
i don't run my life in my business
thinking oh i'm going to make sure that
we don't lose money and i want to make
sure we don't go bust and we want to i'm
not really bothered and i think that
do you know what it's really interesting
some people get rich and they lose all
the money yeah and they get rich again
who knows that yeah you know what that
is go on do you know yeah i know god why
because it's in their blueprint they're
just those type of people they're just
they're good at making money they can
find they find solutions and problems so
yeah should they lose their money that's
like okay what am i going to do next
yeah you're right it is their thermostat
but there's a far deeper reason oh go on
enlighten me samuel all right i hope you
i hope you guys are enjoying this as
well if you are hit the like button
um
if this lives up to your expectations
now after the build up
right now this is the reason it's really
interesting so what you think about
expands
thoughts lead to things
okay
so hear me so
when you've got nothing
you're wanting money
so you're thinking about making money
and wealth and and then
you make it
but then when you make the money you're
like i've got the money you then think
oh i hope i don't lose it
and you're thinking about losing it
and then you lose it and then you're
self-sabotaged right because what you
think about happens if you're thinking
about if i'm thinking
i better not spill this drink i better
not spill the string i better not spill
this drink i'll spill the drink yeah
right what you what you think about
happens so if i'm thinking about i don't
want to lose money now i don't want to
lose it i don't want to lose i don't
want to lose it
very very interesting anyway on that
note
[Music]
enjoy have a wonderful day i'm off now
to
heathrow i've got a crash course uh
property millionaire intensive i'm on
stage in about 25 minutes so you need to
get going i need to go and i need to get
this uploaded so you can watch it don't
forget to
like this video comment down below if
you have any questions for us and
subscribe
[Music]